dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here in an
earlier episode we showcased the
technique for summarizing images not in
a word but an entire sentence that
actually makes sense if you were
spellbound by those results you'll be
out of your mind when you hear this one
let's turn it around and ask a neural
network to have a sentence as an input
and ask it to generate images according
to it not fetching already-existing
images from somewhere generating new
images according to these sentences is
this for real this is an idea that is
completely out of this world a few years
ago is someone proposed such an idea and
hoped that any useful result can come
out of this that person would have
immediately been transported to an
asylum the important key word here is
zero shot recognition before we go to
the zero part let's talk about one-shot
learning one-shot learning means a class
of techniques that can learn something
from one or at most a handful of
examples deep neural networks typically
required to see hundreds of thousands of
marks before they can learn the concept
of a mug however if I show one mug to
any of you fellow scholars you will of
course immediately get the concept of a
mug at this point it is amazing what
these deep neural networks can do but
with the current progress in this area
I'm convinced that in a few years
feeding millions of examples to a deep
neural network to learn such a simple
concept will be considered a crime until
zero short recognition the zero shot is
pretty simple
it means zero training samples but this
sounds preposterous what it actually
means is that we can train our neural
network to recognize Birds tiny things
what the concept of blue is what a crown
is but then we ask it to show us an
image of a tiny bird with a blue crown
essentially the neural networking learns
to combine these concepts together and
generate new images leaning on these
learned concepts and I think this paper
is a wonderful testament as to why two
minute papers
is such a strident advocate of deep
learning and why more people should know
about these extraordinary works about
the paper it is really well-written
there are quite a few treats in there
for scientists game theory and minimax
optimization among other things cupcakes
for my brain we will definitely talk
about these topics in later two minute
papers episodes stay tuned
but for now you shouldn't only read the
paper you should devour it and before we
go let's address the elephant in the
room the output images are tiny because
this technique is very expensive to
compute prediction two papers down the
line it will be done in a matter of
seconds two even more papers down the
line it will do animations in full HD
until then I'll sit here stunned by the
results and just frown and wonder thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time